im
so ah teams hat mal wieder an meinem mikrofon rumgestellt nice nice sehr gut
gemacht teams teams hatte überhaupt nicht an meinem mikrofon doch natürlich hat
teams an meinem mikrofon rumgestellt ich hatte es zuletzt irgendwie auf 77 oder so
echt macht sie erst auch was am mikrofon ja mit voice chat mit in game voice chat
du machst immer auf 69 krasser dude hier macht auf 69 da ist bestimmt noch keine
erfahrt hier drauf gekommen das zu machen aber morgen informatikprüfung
lerne mir mal wie man ein oah kannst du denn auch schön den binary tree
inverten
ich weiß nicht mehr was ein huff huff mann baum überhaupt ist zeigt mal her
ok ich glaube jetzt weiß ich was es ist das ist high IQ zeug
ich bin übelst müde leute sachs euch ich war zwei stunden wieder laufen also
wisst was schon der laufe verstehe ja und ich habe stellt euch mal vor ich
habe noch weiter abgenommen jetzt steht schon fast fast ich würde sagen
paar tage braucht es noch fast schon eine 96 vorne auf der wage oder ich muss
mich einfach mal nach dem frühstück naggisch nachdem ich auf dem clover auf
die waage stellen dann wahrscheinlich auch das ist mir zu residenz lieb was
sack besser
das hat so viel relaxing relaxing übrigens sind bei euch auch die youtube
comments kaputt jetzt erscheinen sie auf einmal wieder zu gehen aber zwisch
zwischenzeitlich weil sind die sind die ziemlich sind die ziemlich am arsch
gewesen
du du du du du du
damit da wird man wenigstens wach bei wie ich so nicht mit klamotten ne
das ist ja überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar
ich bin so immer harte etf alles klar leute ok passt mal auf für super
high IQ sachen habe ich heute bin ich heute nicht in der lage übrigens ich
habe gelesen dhl hat die preise erhöht wurde ja auch mal echt wieder zeit das
ist alles ehe viel zu billig gewesen preis preis preis und guck mal die
helppakete teurer post kostet glaube ich auch 85 cent oder so pro brief wobei ich
keine brief verschicke wobei doch leute ich wisst ihr wisst ihr ich glaube ich
habe tatsächlich mal ein brief verschickt so in letzter zeit ein bisschen
wofür das war ich hatte eine zecke weird champ und man kann im internet
labore beauftragen dass sie die zecke untersuchen und gucken ob da
irgendwelche krankheitserreger drin sind so und ich habe die eingeschickt an
so ein labor das hat 35 euro gekostet und das muss man im brief machen da
füllt man so eine so einen pdf kann man ausdrucken füllt das aus und dann
schickt man diesen antrag mit der zecke hin und ja
folie jose genau nicht pur jose folie jose zeit für zähneputzen fast ja nicht
mehr lange hin ja ich habe die leider abgerissen beim
rausziehen die wollte nicht loslassen was ist denn jetzt der unterschied zeigt
aber was das für was das für eine seite guck ich lieber bei der tagesschau
immerhin dafür bezahle ich immerhin gebühren was kostet es denn jetzt die
ditz die ditz die ditz so die filiale kosten 399 zu voll naja so selten wie ich
was verschicke übrigens leute ich habe mir noch einen zweiten access point auf
ebay bestellt na wisst ihr ich habe den am 30 ersteigert und es ist immer noch
nicht da ich weiß nicht was mit dem dude los ist der scheint es alles der scheint
es nicht losgeschickt zu haben ich glaube der wollten der wollte oder will
mich immer noch scammen da muss ich jetzt bald mal bei ebay in
häkchen hin machen zu habe ich nicht erhalten also ich gebe dem die woche
noch zeit aber wenn das nächste woche nicht da ist dann ist vorbei
ganzen scammer schicke ich kussing hin nach england ich 17 möchte in den
ferien ein freiwilliges praktikum machen irgendwo in der software wirklich so
gute idee wie kommst du darauf hast du irgendwie
andere ok muss aber weiter lesen hast du einen tipp welche firmen ausschauen
warum willst du das denn machen hast du bestimmte hintergründe also erhoffst du
dir vielleicht dass du dann ein jahr später da besser den job wird es oder
interessiert es dich einfach oder musst du irgendwas machen ich meine steht zwar
freiwillig da du hast einfach spaß am programmieren
hu nach welchen firmen du ausschau halten sollst ich denke dass es im
prinzip ähnlich ist wie bei allem nach was man ausschauen sollte ja du solltest
gucken ob sich die firma anspricht also sprich was machen die so ist das was
volle technologie was dich jetzt schon interessiert was ich gefällt vielleicht
hast du schon bisschen vorkenntnisse was macht das was macht das für einen
eindruck auf dich mal auf irgendwelche bewertungsportalen gucken was dort
geschrieben wird keine ahnung also der anderen seite ich weiß nicht wie
einfach ist ein praktikum zu bekommen ich mein schüler praktikum erbarmen
sich vielleicht manche weil man es machen muss aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
ich weiß nicht wie scharf die auf praktikanten sind auf der anderen seite
auf der einen seite würde man denken ja die sollten eigentlich gucken dass die
praktikanten nehmen weil die wollen letztendlich irgendwann mal azubis und
und mitarbeiter haben die suchen ja alle hände ringt und gerade wenn man
händenringt leute sucht ist vielleicht das gute chance auch in zukunft leute
von sich gleich zu überzeugen aber ob die soweit denken da bin ich mir nicht
sicher also ich kann dir jetzt keinen wirklich guten tipp geben bald die sauce
dankeschön für den messer sapper guck mal du hast schon den silber keks bald
gehts aufwärts hier wobei ging ja schon der holz keks ist schon mal weg was
machst du denn privat so also ganz im ernst wenn du es einfach nur just for fun
machen willst beziehungsweise wenn du da wenn du die erhoffst was wirklich zu
lernen ich würde fast sagen wenn du dich die
ferien hinsetzt und ich mit dem privaten projekt beschäftigt lernst du fast mehr
als dort als praktikant weil als praktikant seriously was macht man als
praktikant die lassen sich in den shit machen wurde nichts großartiges bei
lernst gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus praktikanten jobs und gut vielleicht
kannst du ein bisschen geld verdienen je nachdem was es ist aber du lernst
vielleicht bisschen die business seite in der it kennen dass es halt nicht
immer um technik geht sondern auch viel oftmals um sinnlose bussen stonks
entscheidungen moin markt sein video war wieder geil so gelacht poch war durch
wahrheit des video deck du schreibst du schreibst das falsches cousin heißt
das cousin das muss man genauso das schreibt man genauso wie man es
ausspricht keckel kommt dann bestimmt mit den hier kommt mit dem opel agila der
kommt aber nicht mit dem 2001er modell der kommt stimmt noch mit dem 2000er
modell besoß money weißt du was das geile ist du gibst mir das money und
besoß behält großteil davon besoß bezahlt sich selbst quasi aber
dankeschön für den zapp
bei uns bekommen anwendungsentwicklung dazu bis immer ein pizza shop zum bauen
mit pp pp was ist denn los
ich hatte heute auf der aber gender diskussion ganz ehrlich ich würde da
gar nicht darauf einsteigen das thema ist so aufgehitzt und normal
drüber reden ist es bisschen wie es ist ein bisschen wie ja doch trifft es
eigentlich ganz gut ich wollte sagen das ist ein bisschen wie gendern bei wie
man das jetzt schreiben sollte alles da hat auch jeder irgendwie eine meinung
zu und lässt da auch nichts anderes gelten das heißt eigentlich ziemlich
müßig darüber zu diskutieren es ist aber eine beliebte diskussion wo sich
alle daran beteiligten können weil jeder hat eine meinung zu jeder kann
dazu irgendwas sagen letztendlich ist es aber eines der
unwisslich unbedeutendsten unwichtigsten probleme ob wir da jetzt
sternchen innen slash innen doppelpunkt innen oder kauffrauen kaufmänner oder
wie auch immer eigentlich ist wichtig ist ja bei geschriebenen sachen meiner
ansicht nach hauptsächlich erst mal dass die intention des schreibers gut
rüberkommt und da was auch immer ich glaube das nee hatte ich noch nicht ich
beteilige mich wie gesagt aber an solchen sachen auch nicht das ist mir
zu doof
ja das ist darf da habe ich kein bock drüber mal zu diskutieren was die leute
immer ein bisschen vergessen ich sage ich finde das kann man nicht oft genug
sagen es wird ja durch diese diskussionen ich
finde es prinzipiell nicht schlecht dass solche diskussionen geführt für gar
nicht diskutieren ist gut ich mag das wenn die leute auch mal was sagen was
vielleicht nicht so gut bei allen ankommt ist habe ich überhaupt habe ich
überhaupt kein problem zu ja ich habe auch kein problem mit meiner leute
kontroverse videos machen also ist überhaupt kein ding aber gerade bei
dieser diskussion das gibt ja noch deutlich mehr in dieser
richtung da wo twitter immer eskaliert bei über diesen themen eine sache ich
finde die kann man nicht oft genug sagen das ist dass es immer so wirkt weil da
hier so richtig heiß und hitzig drüber diskutiert wird dass es so wirkt als ist
das irgendwie zur aktuellen zeit alles quasi so schlimm wie noch nie ja die
welt ist so intolerant wie noch nie die welt ist so rassistisch wie noch nie die
welt ist frauenfeindlich wie noch nie in wirklichkeit ist es genau umgedreht die
welt war noch nie ich rede jetzt von hier ja wenn man bei
nahen osten gucken sieht das da wieder anders aus die welt war noch nie so
tolerant wie heute und was persönliche entfaltung angeht ist das die beste
zeit in der in der wir leben können könnten wie soll man sagen ja gut wir
leben jetzt in der aktuellen zeit das ist die beste zeit die sie gegeben hat für
persönliche entfaltung und das ist allein schon ja auch wenn du dir das
gaming thema anguckst ja früher wurde das so dargestellt als sind das alles
irgendwelche kleinen stuben kellerhocker was jetzt im kurzen teils sogar so
stimmt ich meine ich rede nur von mir ja und da kannst du überhaupt nichts
sinnvolles mit anfangen mittlerweile ist gaming mainstream guckt euch mal an pro
gamer haben die hottesten girlfriends chillen mit den hottesten dudes und
wären die freshesten clothes ja ist halt so das ist heute ganz normal also für
persönliche entfaltung ist es die beste zeit und es hat sich die letzten ich
will es nicht übertreiben mit 100 jahren aber die letzten 100 jahre natürlich
ganz besonders viel aber es hat sich letzten im letzten jahrhundert schon
bis jetzt hat sich so viel zum positiven gewendet wenn man man darf nicht
vergessen schwulen sein war noch eine krankheit von ich allzu langer zeit und
man dachte babies empfinden keine schmerzen solche komischen dinge also
man hat sich so aus vielen aspekten hat man sich deutlich weiterentwickelt die
letzten 100 jahre und man soll jetzt nicht so tun als wäre das heute so
schlimm wie noch nie uns geht es heute ziemlich gut und das muss man auch denke
ich manchmal zu schätzen wissen
was nicht heißt dass es nicht doch irgendwelche probleme gibt die gibt es
in allen bereichen natürlich nicht so dass alles friede freute eierkuchen
wäre aber soll ich da meine ähnliche meinung noch noch auch zu so einer
allgemeinsache sagen ich finde die leute sollen sich ein bisschen mehr mal um ihren
eigenen scheiß kümmern ein bisschen weniger empört sein über jeden kram
sondern mal ein bisschen vor der eigenen haustür kehren und auch mal sich ein
bisschen gedanken um ihr eigenes leben machen um und um ihren eigenen scheiß
da merken sie vielleicht dass es ihnen gar nicht so geil geht wie sie sich das
vielleicht in ihren köpfen vorstellen also das ist auch das gefühl die haben
alle keine eigenen probleme ja zum beispiel ja ja genau
da gab es viele da gab es haare sträubende sachen ist alles teilweise
gar nicht lange her und es muss man wirklich auch mal zu schätzen wissen
dass es uns heute ziemlich gut geht also ich rede von hier ja gerade wo wir sind
in der aktuellen zeit
stream ja ich habe jetzt stream streak gehabt guckt mal stream streak recent
broadcasts guck mal ich habe gestreamt heute gestern vorgestern 1 2 3 4 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 9 10 an einem tag habe ich sogar zweimal gestreamt guckt euch das an 6
stunden 10 minuten 11 hier habe ich einen tag nicht gestreamt 12 hier wird es
wieder ein bisschen weniger ofi streamer ja siehst du geht geht los ja jetzt ist
es soweit kündigung ist raus leute ich muss nicht was zum thema kündigung
erzählen ich habe euch ja erzählt dass bei uns gerade auf der arbeit um
strukturiert wird und ich dachte mir so weißt du was du fragst jetzt einfach mal
dein chef sag mal hier wenn es demnächst die umstrukturierung gibt schreibt mir
doch mal ein zwischenzeugnis oder meinte man chef zu mir nein sie haben zu ihm
gesagt bei solchen fragen soll er sagen gibt es gerade nicht
habe ich mir gedacht was wollte ich verarschen wie gibt es nicht oder habe
ich mal drüber nachgedacht warum es das nicht gibt die haben wahrscheinlich
wirklich bedenken dass ihnen die leute wegrennen weil die wissen genau wenn die
leute sich zeugnisse holen heißt dass die wollen sich woanders bewerben
näher doch doch so einfach ist das gar nicht wenn du kündigt müssen sie dir
zeugnis geben zwischen zwischen zeugnisse ist immer so eine sache da
braucht es einen trifftigen anlass ein führungskräftewechsel ist aber in der
regel ein anlass sie haben gesagt ja ja das machen wir dann irgendwann wenn die
diese umstrukturierung vorbei ist weiß ich ob mein chef dann überhaupt noch da
ist dann schreibt ihnen random dude den ich den mit dem ich fünf jahre lang
nichts zu tun hatte mein mein zeugnis also ich bin ich bin ich bin kurz ich
bin wirklich am überlegen ob ich nicht zum betriebsrat mal zumindest eine
anfrage schicke ob das denn so alles da auch bekannt ist weil das sehe ich nicht
ein also ganz ehrlich das kann ich zu viel erwartet sein
ich weiß an meinem chef nichts nicht der soll nicht aber trotzdem also ist
grenzwertig ich bin ich bin gespannt ich habe am freitag am freitag wie gesagt
ich habe ja gar nicht wirklich vorzukündigen es sei denn die machen so
eins zwei sachen mit denen ich wirklich nicht leben könnte eins davon ist
beispielsweise homeoffice abschaffen ich habe am freitag ein gespräch mit meinem
jetzigen chef und mit meinem theoretisch dann neuen chef wobei das ja alles nicht
so klar ist und der da muss ich da muss ich ein paar dinger loswerden ein paar
dinger fragen und je nachdem was dann rauskommt mal gucken
vielleicht muss ich meine skills bald anderweitig feil bieten und jetzt mal
etwas gewählter auszudrücken
ja finde ich auch deswegen will ich das ja gerade machen das da
weil i quit netflix wir essen das von dem haben wir doch auch schon mal sachen
ach das ist ja damit der typ mit dem mit dem rust
irgendwas haben wir von dem schon mal geguckt
moment nee ist das der vim typ ist es ist es der vim typ der so der so ultra
eskaliert beim beim vim tippen kann das sein vor dem haben wir schon was
geguckt wo ich mir auch genau what the fuck
stimmt das ist der mit diesem genau das ist stimmt das ist der mit diesem
super ergonomischen keyboard ja wo ich nie drüber nie drauf tippen könnte
weil es mir viel zu ergonomisch ist
ja natürlich was meinst du was ich vor habe aber die haben gesagt er soll nicht
also wie gesagt ich bin da weil er nachdem was am freitag rauskommt ich habe
schon einen vom betriebsrat angeschrieben ich will ihr einfach mal fragen ob das
da so bekannt ist und was was das jetzt soll ja
wohl kommt keckel plötzlich weil ich gestern auf die idee gekommen bin warum
hat eigentlich noch niemanden lull und keck weh miteinander verbunden zu
keckel und dann habe ich einfach mal eingegeben ffz keckel und da ist mir
aufgefallen ok auf die idee ist schon jemand gekommen
und bei der gelegenheit habe ich einfach keckel auch mal gerade geedet
keckel
ok
oktawim respekt genau ach du hast ja gesagt im ex ja im ex ist tatsächlich
ripp ich weiß nicht wer noch im ex verwendet wahrscheinlich so gut wie
keiner mehr wird mich echt mal getappt moment moment das muss ich mal kurz
checken haben die ach mir ja natürlich moment moment
moment der geht ja garantiert nicht zu einer microsoft gehörenden geht front
end seite denn das ist dass das im ex wird doch im leben nicht auf github
sein genau der genau genau der also ich glaube im ex ist wirklich auf dem
absteigenden ast schon eine ganze weile und spätestens seit wishlist studio code
die die plugin möglichkeit bietet weil ganz ehrlich eines der riesen vorteile
von imex aber halt natürlich schon lange vor wishlist studio code war die
erweiterbarkeit durch addons und addons wirklich alle art ja und es gab ja
zwischenzeitlich mal so den running gag welches betriebssystem benutzt du ja
im ex aber mittlerweile gehen da auch viele moderne sachen nicht mehr
gescheit
zum beispiel browser kannst vergessen im ex einzige browser die du im ex
verwenden kannst ist wenn du grafisch im ex verwendest und einen gtk widget mit
einem webkit was aber auch ziemlicher müll ist
selber klasse dankeschön für den sub et hex editor jetzt war ernsthaft wer
wer braucht also cringe werden text editor braucht wir machen nur noch echo
in echo in files echo seht
muss reichen
ja können wir uns das angucken wenn der chatter schon gepostet hat warum nicht
was kriege ich da eigentlich wieder für komische videos empfiehlen was why you
should learn wim in 2020 weil wim der beste kommando zeilen editor ist den
skippt nano outdated overrated schibatet free wifi neighbors neighbors stolen
laptop free entertainment nehmen wir auch immer
wim ist der beste kommando zeilen editor gibt es nix nano ist nicht
angesagt nano sagt nano ist quasi ein ganz normaler editor wie man ihn kennt
plus dass man halt mit der maus nicht gescheitere rumklicken kann was normale
editoren erträglich macht ich weiß dass man theoretisch mit der maus klicken
könnte aber normalerweise nicht nano sagt
ich kann ich ich kann ganz passabel wim aber nicht für die krassen hacker
mann sachen wie manch andere ja wim oder ist es egal also ich habe ich habe
wim sehr lange verwendet übertrieben customise mit wirklich so vielen
plugins dass ich nicht mal abdecken konnte und dass die hälfte von meinem
editor kaputtgegangen ist entweder habe ich mwim habe ich auch eine ganze zeit
verwendet dank diesen ganzen asynchronen sachen die reingepatcht
wurden aber mittlerweile bin ich so weit weg von plugins ich habe eine wim konfig
in der die hat keine ahnung 60 zeilen oder so das sind einfach von konfig
gesetzt fertig und deswegen ist für mich egal ob wim oder oder neo wim für
alles andere verwende ich mittlerweile also ich verwende wim nur noch für
kommando zeilen editing wenn ich irgendwie einfach sage ich muss ich
müsste mal schnell in den textfile editieren auf der auf der kommando zeile
easy
ich will so das gehört man so und ansonsten ich habe in der studio code für
frontend sachen eigentlich ziemlich exklusiv für frontend sachen ok ich
habe es letztendlich auch für c++ verwendet kek weight und ansonsten
verwende ich eigentlich das komplette jet-brains sortiment weil ich habe mir
irgendwann mal dieses all all products pack gegönnt und ja ich habe es mir
wirklich gekauft es gibt ja immer noch leute die glauben es mir nicht obwohl ich
euch schon den lizenzbildschirm gekauft habe die sagen immer noch max max kappa
kappa gekauft nein ich habe es mir wirklich gekauft ich meine ich verdiene
damit direkt und indirekt geld also warum soll ich mir das nicht kaufen
ich will es genau hier ich will es und es ist auch gar nicht so teuer es ist auch
gar nicht so teuer wenn man sich anguckt das kostet ab dem dritten jahr dann
irgendwie nur noch 180 euro oder so im jahr das ist echt in ordnung also da
kann ich mich jetzt nicht beschweren für das was man bekommt zumal zumal guck
mal die haben so viele sachen und ich benutze davon zwar jetzt nicht alles aber
ich benutze ich benutze sie leihen ich benutze rider ich benutze go land und ich
benutze manchmal relativ selten pietscher früher habe ich ruby mein noch
ab und zu verwendet als ich ruby gemacht habe webstorm bin ich nicht wirklich
warm damit geworden aber ich verwende den kram ja auch nicht
alles wobei ganz ehrlich keine ahnung gibt es jemand von euch der überhaupt
weiß was data kripp und data spell ist data kripp haben wir einmal verwendet
das weiß ich noch wo ich irgendwelche sql dinger gemacht habe aber auch nur
weil ich wissen wollte was es ist ohne mist ich habe es ich habe es
versucht also hier arbeitgeber bezahlen zu lassen das ist bei uns alles so ein
abfakt und ein riesen akt bis da mal irgendwas genehmigt wird ich benutze
das einfach und sobald ich was entwickeln sollen auf der arbeit und ich
nicht die möglichkeit habe das von mir daheim aus von der vm zu machen sage ich
geht nicht hab die tools nicht dafür hatte schon ein paar mal wunder gewirkt
habe ich euch eigentlich die story erzählt ja habe ich euch erzählen ich
habe doch auch ich habe ich habe euch doch erzählt dass ich mal präsentation
gehalten habe über unsere verkackte arbeitsweise dass das so nicht möglich
ist ja und daraufhin hieß es dann ja dann machen wir euch jetzt in azure
einfach ein paar linux vms nice poc macht man ja die gibt es jetzt und die
funktionieren auch tatsächlich ganz gut manchmal hilft das wirklich ungemein wenn
man einfach sagt kann ich nicht machen habe ich die tools nicht für oder sagt
alle wie da muss ich dann so doofe fragen wie warum hast du dir nie was
gesagt was meint ihr denn war ich das letzte halbe jahr oder ja oder zwei jahre
oder drei jahre schon mache warum haben die für jede sprache eine
eigene idee das ist eine gute frage die könnten bestimmt alles als intelli j
plugins bringen ich weiß es nicht
sonst zu bloatet vielleicht besseres product sortiment dass man sagen kann
das verkaufen das verkaufen mal gucken also vielleicht kommt mit flit was
interessantes ja kann ja sein
ich könnte es mir auch nicht mehr vorstellen fulltime im terminal zu
hackermannen gerade da nachdem ich jetzt ja aktuell auch relativ viel c-sharp
mache c-sharp war in wim schon immer richtiger painstab ich weiß gibt leute
die machen das ich kann es nicht kann es nicht verstehen aber das will man nicht
im terminal machen ist immer noch beste ja wenn du wenn du irgendwelche sachen
starten muss wenn du irgendwas um kopieren muss wenn du irgendwas nachgucken
muss besser aber rein sagen wir jetzt für dotnet entwicklung ist die jet
prince idee das beste da kann ganz ehrlich da kann wishell studio nicht
mithalten wishell studio der einzige fordern von wishell studio ist
manchmal wenn sie ganz neuen shit haben dass der halt noch nicht in rider drin
ist aber das ist meistens auch nur bei preview versionen wobei ich sagen muss
bei dotnet fünf war es glaube ich da waren die bei rider ziemlich langsam da
hat es bis nach release gebracht gedauert bis alles halbwegs gut
unterstützt zwar
sieht jemand eine chance ohne großartige programmier erfahrung einen job in der
richtung zu finden june und habt ihr mit am besten also wenn du junior bist da
musst du auf jeden fall programmieren können
es ist halt die frage was du kannst ich meine wenn ohne großartige erfahrung
bedeutet du kannst es nicht da kannst du nicht programmierer werden das ist klar
ist ja logisch irgendwo wenn du einfach nur sagst ja also wenn du von dir sagen
würdest ja ich kann das eigentlich aber ich habe jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so
viel an erfahrung vorzuweisen also belastbar so nach dem motto ich war jetzt
schon zwei jahre da zwei jahre da hat so sowas in der richtung dann geht
eigentlich nur probieren
ansonsten github account darauf ordentliche projekte haben hilft mit
sicherheit gute bewerbung schreiben hilft mit sicherheit sich den passenden job
raussuchen dass zu dem passt was man schon kann hilft mit sicher auch und einen
guten eindruck machen hilft mit sicherheit auch oder du gehst irgendwo
hin die so desperate sind die so die so kurz vorm quasi kurz vorm untergehen
stehen weil sie keine leute finden aber die diese ledigen sind in der regel
kacke da will man dann wahrscheinlich nicht
hin ab wie viele sternen ist ein projekt
ordentlich ich würde gar nicht nach sternen gehen
ich meine wenn du vielleicht ein repo hast mit ein paar sternen ist nicht
verkehrt aber ich meine eher mit ordentlichen projekten also mit mit gut
vorzeigbaren projekten ja wo man hat auch sieht du weißt was du machst
jetzt nicht so wie ich teilweise wenn man sich meine githubs sachen anguckt
wo ich teilweise aus meme gründen irgendwas besonders unordentlich mache
oder einfach weil ich keinen bock habe das ist nicht das beste zum vorzeigen
das sollte das sollten halt schöne schöne werbeprojekte im endeffekt dann
sein für dich wenn du natürlich was hast was gut ankommt auch viele sterne hat
es sicherlich noch mal extra bonus aber ich bin kein personal abteilungs mensch
keine ahnung wie kann man unter wimm nachträglich den user wechseln
beziehungsweise die zerteilen ins ruhtrecht das ist relativ einfach das ist
so einfach dass ich aus dem kopf nicht mehr weiß wie es ging aber es gibt was
gar es gibt einen ganz simplen kurzen befehl paar zeilen um das zu machen aber
ich kriege es aus dem kopf nicht hin das ist einfach wenn man es ein paar mal
gemacht hat easy
ich versuche mich gerade im zuge wo ich mich best skript beschäftigt auch mit
wim ja es ist besser ja für kommando zeilen editieren ist das beste und
wisst ihr was der riesen vorteil von wimm ist erstens es ist überall drauf
und gerade wenn man ein bisschen was macht richtung administration ihr müsst
jetzt kein systematministrator sein oder so aber mal auf ich den server einloggen
oder sei es nur bei azure auf irgendeine cli oder sonst wie es ist überall auf
irgendeine vm oder so wo ihr ein user habt auf den switch einloggen irgendwo
ist vollkommen egal es gibt ein wimm und wenn ihr wisst wie man sich in wimm
bewegt könnt ihr über ssh auch gut sachen editieren
es gibt tatsächlich leute leute wisst ihr was ich bei uns schon gesehen habe da
musste ich da musste ich wirklich extrem laut kecken als ich das gesehen habe
ohne scheiß ich habe mal ich war bei einem
entwickler ok ich weiß nicht ob ich den entwickler nennen sollte der macht
hauptsächlich jetzt halt euch fest wordpress und der hat jetzt ungelogen ich
meine hat einen account gehabt ja auf der linux kiste weil da schiebt er
öfters mal irgendwelche neuen seiten drauf so und wisst ihr was der gemacht
hat als der irgendwas in php irgendwelche php sachen editieren wollte
oder konfix editieren ich weiß nicht mehr der hat pass auf der win s cp auf
gemacht hat die datei rüber auf windows gezogen hat notepad plus plus aufgemacht
hat die datei editiert gespeichert und damit win s cp wieder rüber kopiert
jetzt schimpf alter
und wisst ihr was danach war danach hatte die datei encoding probleme weil
windows zeilen endings drin waren
ihr kennt ja die geschichte mit carriage return new line oder new line oder nur
carriage return oder was auch immer es hat linux anders als mech alles als
windows alles mit so was wie git muss zu dem gar nicht ankommen
das da habe ich da habe ich echt nur mit dem kopf geschüttelt als ich das
gesehen habe
ja finde ich auch gut dann gewöhnt man sich nämlich nicht an
irgendwelchen zusatz krempel der auf server nicht voll ist wenn ihr das ich
hatte sogar mal in meiner zeit wo ich mein vim zur idee ausgebaut hatte ich
hatte ein ssh script was ich habe laufen lassen bei jedem login was dort meinen
vim ordner hingesüngt hat ich habe immer 20 30 mb vim ordner gesüngt als ich auf
den neuen auf eine neue kiste gegangen bin das war eine blöde idee weil auf
manchen switchen und so geht das halt nicht weil ich mich auf switchen sehr
selten einbocke für benutzer von konkurrenzprodukten ja ich benutze
studio
wo steht das andere kommerzieller tools ach so
ich dachte ich könnte sagen ich benutze studio ich würde gern euren kram
verwenden dass das so so einfach ist es anscheinend nicht her
spiel diablo 2 reforged viel besser diablo 2 sind wir noch das beste diablo
ok habe ich mit dem all habe ich eigentlich mit diesem all all dings
booms pack intelli j ultimate ist ist ist das da damit drinne ja ok gut klar so
klar ist bei so was nie was spukig musik hier ich nutze data kripp ist quasi wie
table ich weiß ich hab keine ahnung was table plus ist data spellings für data
sites die haben aber auch für jeden shit irgendwas oder und da kriege ich
angst dass es mir zu hat es luigi's mansion da klar und ich kann sagen dass
mir zu zu zu zu aufwühlend hier bist du ein data scientist
genau einfach kita account anlegen to do list ab rein rein pushen in der
jeweiligen technologie was die was die haben wollen und schon ist die
bewerbung sicher easy ganz einfach so muss man leute ich bin wirklich froh dass
übermorgen schon feiertag ist freitag muss leider arbeiten aber das ist nicht
schlimm da passiert eh nix was ist ein gutes terminal für linux
tja normalerweise hätte ich gesagt gnome terminal aber gnome terminal ist
total outdated jebaited overrated habe ich dem letzt gelernt sogar so so
outdated dass das gar nicht mehr weiterentwickelt wird anscheinend habe ich
auch habe ich habe ich vom chat gelernt
wusste ich nicht
mit fisch bin ich bis jetzt noch nicht warm geworden vielleicht soll ich mir
das einfach mal wieder angucken wobei ich bin mit ich bin mit zsh glücklich
zsh wissen was das coole an zsh ist zsh spricht jeder anders aus
ja also zsh ist auch zsh es gibt leute die sagen noch was anderes keine ahnung
zschell habe ich auch schon gehört fisch ist relativ klar wie man das aus
spricht
wo ich will studio kostet in der community version gar nichts und der
unterschied ist eigentlich kaum vorhanden guck mal hier siehst du den
vergleich unterstütze ist komplett irrelevant ist sogar das gleiche ist auch
komplett irrelevant ist komplett irrelevant es ist eigentlich ich
verstehe den also ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht warum man sich studio
professionell kaufen sollte ich habe noch nichts vermisst im normalen studio
bis ich reiter verwendet habe und reiter ist einfach in allen belangen die
bessere idee wie gesagt außer für ganz super neue pleating edge features und
studio professionell bringt jetzt ja nix dabei was das irgendwie sinnvoll
erweitern würde also ich weiß nicht wozu man das braucht das ist eine
äußerst aussage lose tabelle ja
code lens war code lens nicht dieser versuch von microsoft so was wie
github co-pilot light zu machen somit welche metoden werden besonders oft
verwendet und so was braucht kein mensch wirklich kein mensch was ich mag bei den
microsoft tools aber das benutze ich im studio code ist live share live share
verwende ich tatsächlich auf der arbeit relativ oft da kann man
tatsächlich ganz gut sich mit anderen leuten was angucken und es ist
microsoft man hat ja bei uns mal entschieden dass weil wir seit wenn wir
microsoft azure verwenden dass wir microsoft prinzipiell vertrauen vielleicht
nicht die schlauste entscheidung aber eine entscheidung
ja so ungefähr habe ich das gemacht damals ich glaube ich hab es eher so
dass es schneller geht ja es ist zum größten lizenz also weniger von den tools
ja es gibt ein paar test tools glaube ich aber ganz ehrlich auch kein
ja leute da ist also jemand der mit win scp pp dateien hin und her kopiert und
dann ist line ending versaut dem kannst du bestimmt entkommen mit ssh fs für
windows das ist vorbei das überstreikt steigt komplett sein knowledge horizont
reiner home office ja ganz ehrlich ich vermeide es eh nach frankfurt zu fahren
so lange die bahn aktuell so überfolgt ist überfüllt ist seit 9 euro tickets
ich finde es halt auf der einen seite gut dass es 9 euro tickets gibt einfach
dass mehr leute mal in den genuss kommen festzustellen wie beschissen die bahn
ist vielleicht wirkt sich sehr langfristig tatsächlich positiv aus aber
ansonsten ist es halt scheiße ja das jet planes zeug ist gut das höre ich von
allen ecken und enden also halt auch vor leuten die tools verwenden die ich nicht
verwende und die müssen schon was richtig machen
kotlin ist bei uns beispielsweise bei unseren java leuten auf der arbeit total
angesagt die sind nur ein bisschen pissed dass sie auf der arbeit nicht
verwenden können weil die irgendwie der meinung sind nein nein nur plane java
ist beste java cool retrotor das kenne ich dass dieser der aussicht
monitor ne ja genau das ist eher für für die memes nicht wirklich um damit zu
arbeiten was sind eigentlich die aktuellen github trends zeigt doch mal
hier aber wenn man gerade dabei was sind die aktuellen github trends was ist
denn skills ah achso
also mal gucken was hat was was was trendet denn aktuell auf shit ab wir
gucken einmal allgemein und dann gucken wir mal
nähe nicht nicht nicht spaken language gucken wir was dort net technisch so
trendet aktuell zeigt mir her maui workshop juckt mich nicht steam tools im
tools aha akuma englisch keine ahnung nix was ich brauchen würde fast shit
ab pdf patcher sp dot net core archie steam farm was moment moment was sie
schab application für das farmen von steam karts was genau machen die da was
sind steam karts und was kann man die farmen also steam karts ist wahrscheinlich
sowas wie eine google shop karte aber wie farmt man steam karts ist das
irgendwas art valve jetzt eine kryptowährung oder was
sammelkarten
das heißt das ding legt einen neuen steam account an und farmen free to play
games für für die die symbole oder wie für die karten oder was
stonks oder das bringt das ok das don't cry so much ich glaube das ist
ziemlich harte harte kost für den stream ach nee das das hast du es geht um
millimeter geschrieben ok dachte da habe ich sie noch nie verstanden wozu man
das braucht ein game win ui gallery ef core habe ich zum glück noch nie
gebraucht das ist chrome embedded jellyfin
ich war sah das ist so ein remod ding das habe ich auch schon mal gesehen
bett btd ist das blundes oder was ist das
er blut tower defense tatsächlich nun oh so man oh so darf natürlich nicht
fehlen was die scharptools ich mein oh so ist an sich ja gar nicht so aber die
ganzen leute spielen in oh so immer irgendwelche anime dinger
kennst du das ist dieses musik game wo die leute dann immer klick klick klick
hui hui hui und zu irgendwelchen anime liedern machen
soll angeblich richtig gutes soll sogar richtig gutes aim training sein habe ich
gehört der ehemalige main dd von ich weiß nicht mal dallas führte von
indem auferwatsch von indem auferwatsch liegt hier man hat immer gesagt er
spielt als aim training nur oh so
ok sag mal es gibt das und es gibt das das exakt das gleiche warum sind das
zwei unterschiedliche warum sind das zwei unterschiedliche repost
what the fuck haben die es gefolgt oder war die seite kann ich öffnen hör mal bloß auf
sofort so gut dann gucken wir mal overall was die aktuellen trends sind
also also was geht auf geht auf shit ab china chinesen knowledge management svg
spinners cool sowas kann man immer mal gebrauchen und hübsch gemacht sind die
auch cool das kann man immer mal gebrauchen sowas oh alter krass ich
glaube heiß ist das projekt mit den meisten sternen was ich je gesehen habe
137.000 ich weiß gar nicht was das projekt mit den meisten sternen ist kann
man man kann github immer noch nicht nach sternen sortieren
rast hat definitiv nicht so viele die rast die rast taskforce ist zwar strong
aber nicht so strong kuck simon's hk
go micro services lead code master nest ist das war das die react variante zu
nuxt und next und sonst was ich kann ich komme bei java script frameworks nicht
mehr mit redis ok verstehe ich was ich sage auch bei uns auf der arbeit redis
es ist redis geht star ranking ja da gibt es ein paar seiten aber da weiß ich
mal nicht wie aktuell die sind schauen wir mal was sind die meist best
bewerteten shithub repos alter der typ hat es aber durchgespielt oder von dem
benutze ich mein gelb prompt hier mein lilux gelb prompt ist ist von dem der
scheint einige poggers sachen zu haben ach das ist der mit diesen awesome lists
das ist den gelb prompt den ich den ich hier verwende ok repositor ist free
code camp hat die meisten neun und sechs eco ist eco nicht in so eine
language trance ich denke so eine lokalisierungs library
nee es ist etwas für plutsch bender was ok das kann china chinesen liken die
sich überarbeitet fühlen oder irgendwie sowas ok coding view js auf view js ist
soweit vorne tatsächlich was haben wir sonst noch zeit mehr view view ist
wirklich krass weit vorne ich gar nicht gedacht view ist das das muss man sich
mal auf der zogen cg lassen view ist das meist bewertete das best bewertete
projekt auf github alle anderen sachen da oben drüber es sind ja keine
wirklichen software projekte view ist das best bewertete software projekt auf
ganz github das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht hier das ist so aber nicht so
krass so react ist sogar dahinter tensor flow machine learning big brain shit
bootstrap ok das ist eher historisch vermute ich mal weiß nicht wie
angesagt bootstrap ich habe bootstrap ganz lange nicht mal verwendet
oma ist mir zu bloatet brauche ich alles net flutter tatsächlich so weit oben
ok trotz das linux linux ist erst auf 19
youtube dl zurecht zurecht elektron muss doch sein d3 ok go wo ist denn
das stimmt nicht peißen ist gar nicht dabei die haben wir überhaupt nicht
die haben wir überhaupt nicht aktualisiert guckt mal wer weiß von wann das ist
die haben hier 3 4 6 4 6 7 und jetzt gucken wir mal wenn wir das auf github
aufmachen das ist nicht aktuell aber halbwegs aktuell
immerhin
das ist nicht peißen wir hatten das doch eben offen oder wo sind die trends
nein das ist nicht bei das ist du hast recht das ist algorithms implementet in
peißen ok dann habe ich mich verguckt übrigens wisst ihr immer noch was das
bist das beste github repo ist anime girls holding programming books beste ja
zum beispiel für ruby ja da kann man sich sowas angucken alles klar
ich hatte ehrlich ein bisschen bedenken das aufzumachen
nö bist du nicht ich denke best der unter dem strich immer noch die meist
verbreit zu schnell sein gehe ich von aus
kurz aufholen hier
ob habe ich nicht habe ich habe alles ignoriert die ganzen game shows die
ganzen ankündigungen die letzten tage über waren
park und das ohne ce da hast du aber wieder was du unterwegs hat eine weile
gedauert oder
ja das zeug ist wirklich gut
elambi danke für den zapp sorry falsch irgendjemand übersehen an mario danke für den zapp
welche twitch rate empfiehlst du bei 40 m 40 du meinst 40 megabit download oder
was oder upload oder was das ist ich traue mich nicht das aufzumachen leute
stimmt aus das ist safe ich glaube ich nicht es ist sehr ok wenn ihr sagt es ist
er warum hat er das denn das ist der ccc typierer warum warum genau hat er das
ach das ist zu beten oder was oder was ist da was soll das geben wenn es fertig
ist
kein barrierefreier beschlagnahmungs hinweis oder anzeige ist raus so genug
chat gelesen und lasse lasse uns doch mal lasst uns noch mal irgendwas angucken die
letzten 40 minuten wo ich am start bin der typ ist egal die machen ja mittlerweile also
sehen den ort in in wales glaube ich oder so die machen ja mittlerweile damit richtig
kohle die verkaufen die ortsschilder und sowas
mein eigenes video kurz kurz view time generieren ich mute mich auch es hat einer gesagt im
heutigen video ich soll mal auf eines meiner ganz alten battlefield videos reacten und
zwar würde ich da irgendeins raussuchen wo ich mich so richtig drüber aufrege wie abgefuckt
battlefield 3 ist weil da ist wieder irgendwas verkackt hat und ihm heute und aus 2022 sicht
hätte ich halt muss ich dann sagen wir konnten damals ja noch gar nicht ahnen was da kommt
gibt es im hintergrund über view time klar gibt es view time wobei keine ahnung ich hoffe
doch google sollte also man sollte eigentlich auf der seite nicht doch man bekommt das mit
ob die seite aktiv oder inaktiv wird tatsächlich ja 100 dinger web devs schutt schutt no ich
hoffe sind nicht 100 javascript frameworks ok youtube was empfiehlt zu uns denn heute
zeigt man ja gibt es irgendwas gibt es irgendwas spannendes was du immer nicht gucken müsst
also die empfehlungen mann buber das video ist müll ist es da macht meistens gute videos
ja das ist mir jetzt zu lang vor allem interessiert es mich nicht mehr
er hat sich nass gekauft und weiter es ist halt nass und wahrscheinlich in 10 genass
und weiter im text die soll mal lieber 6 machen was sie schon vor irgendwie 100 jahren angekündigt
haben blackboard hits ok eine runde schadenfreude sekunde das ist quasi die commander krieger
schrankvariante nur mit dem tafel oder wie du alter wenn du das abkriegst monka es wenn
du das abkriegst das haut rein das ist nicht wie die wand beim kriegerteam von der seite
gegen kopf kopf erkündigungsvideo netflix ja machen wir das rum ist auch noch richtig
was mit ton an gewandte physik ja der hat der war geschockt
und weiter geht's lässt sich durch nichts aus die rohe bringen also ein beruhigt ich
habe so ganz aber geschwunden schreien sie heute unser dozent fast gestorben
ist ja cool drauf der karl lull ok was soll ich auch mal battlefield video was soll ich
mal das kündigungsvideo von dem typ ok achte leute wir müssen jetzt stark sein ich kenne
paar videos von dem auch die wim videos der ist etwas hyper aktiv müssen wir uns mal
gucken ob ich das ob ich das ertrage ich kann ja sowas normalerweise nicht nicht lange gucken
aber ok so this is the story about how i quit netflix about three years into working at
netflix i was kind of excelling i took on some projects that a lot of people kind of
said no to it turns out that we had groovy on the back end groovy dass das noch jemand
verwendet groovy ich habe in groovy auch mal was gemacht ich habe mal ein confluence
plugin oder sowas ähnliches war kein offizie richtiges plugin ein confluence plugin habe
ich mal in groovy gemacht das war in ordnung aber es ist keine sprache um die ich mich
irgendwie großartig reißen würde yes groovy baby was on the back end it's a terrible jvm
language it absolutely but i just happen to take a little bit of time look up a few things
that you know a few ways to do stuff in groovy and of course i just excelled beyond everybody
else because everybody else is just like i just want to get the stuff done i don't want
to look at it i don't want to be a part of it so i guess what we buy deep good enough
that i could actually build a bunch of different backends so i got selected to kind of do this
kind of large improvement that would make it so that we could have extra metadata about
every single video in the television catalog and of course from there they put me onto an
open source project that was related it was called falcor no not the luck dragon okay
though named after the luck dragon not a luck dragon effectively what falcor was is you
can pass on it like alda es fällt mir unglaublich schwer dieser sache zu folgen überhaupt
graf q l u provide an array of kind of strings or numbers and it would go off onto the back
end and grab all that data like ich war wenn er so ein coolen screenscreen im hintergrund
hat er ja was auf dem screenscreen screenscreen machen kann yes i just said squeal hey i'd
also be feeling if you hit that sub button thanks baby
anywho so this was like my dream job i got to go to that is that is we let's play das
ist wie so ultra hype let's player nur dass er was über wim und netflix erzählt
i got to speak both in the uk i got to speak multiple times in amsterdam got to do a bunch
of different places throughout the united states it was awesome open source circuit the dream
life right it was fantastic actually it wasn't that fantastic now i think in today's day
and age that that really is the dream life that is what a lot of people kind of aspire
to be working full time while getting paid while working on open source but let me tell
you i i would i really had a hard time and this is the reason why we are a small team
about four of us devs all working on a couple different products for the ui kind of team
we are called the ui platform at the time and during this one of the roles was kind of like
a non-coding architect really deciding how things should work and of course this role
kind of appears from various companies and people really have strong feelings about these
kind of roles me personally i greatly dislike non-coding architects reason why i feel like
they get so abstracted from reality that they start ich werde ich wäre schon zufrieden
wenn architekten wenn wenn die architekten bei uns überhaupt irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise
wissen was sie denn eigentlich da unten drunter als architektieren ja also wir haben architekten
für sagen wir irgendwelche systemlandschaften die haben in ihrem leben noch keine liegungskiste
administriert mal zumindest ein bisschen ich meine muss er sich da in der krasse liegungs
heckermann sein aber das busy ahnung ist doch nicht verkehrt oder building things that though
they look great on a whiteboard we're talking lab coats clipboards those little goggles
to protect your eyes things are looking great but when you actually implement it it's nothing
but a dumpster fire of logical inconsistenz ja gut das ist ja normal dass die dass die
planung mit dem ersten kontakt in der realität selten stand hält so of course this was going
on and for about a year i just like i was programming like 60 hours a week i was putting in best
choice money frage wobei es ist jason ist jason nicht in zum griechische held gewesen
effort and it was just starting to feel more and more soul crushing and i can still remember
it must have been december 28 29 27 shortly after christmas walking into my backyard at
like seven at night having a long conversation i did not want to have discussing some of
the internal details about falcor oh we want also er ist um 19 uhr in sein garten gegangen
und hat diskutiert noch über interne architektursachen von diesem software projekt alles klar und
das fand er kacke make this pivot oh this is actually going to be the greatest most ergonomic
most developer experience change in the universe and i remember that was kind of like the moment
i snapped right like i could not handle this project anymore i became pretty dang inferiorated
with it but at the same time something else happened i had another co-worker who was working
beside me also feeling a lot of the same weight and wenn es danach geht wenn wir alle schon
weg wir sind wir sind eigentlich täglich wenn wir irgendwie mieten uns am da drüber auskotzen
was wieder grad für blödsinn gemacht wird stout and kind of start pouring out as you
know his heart wer macht es aber nicht and you know the best way that he could and of
course i was much younger and much dumber at that point and i didn't catch it at all right
in a sense that i was just like yeah i'm kind of upset too but that's about it right i didn't
hear him and i really look back at that as one of my bigger failures in that moment and
really of just of my lifetime in the professional sense you know having someone come to you
and tell you these things and not really try to be there also wenn ich es jetzt richtig
verstanden habe ihm ging es auf den sack wie das projekt gelaufen ist einer seiner erfahrenen
co-worker haben ihm gesagt er ist auch abgefuckt wie das projekt läuft und er hat ein schlechtes
gefühl über das projekt oder irgendwie sowas oder und und er hat nicht drauf gehört so genau so
genau kann ich der sache nicht folgen ehrlich gesagt in approach your boss you know with their
permission of course and really try to create a better team conversation i really wish i would
have taken the control of the situation that i would do today if it was today i would have been
much more forward much more open about everything long before i got to the point what ended up
happening was that i became so sick and so kind of toxified from my job that i started looking
elsewhere and ultimately i did find a different job at corsera yeah corsera online education i had a
good friend there tom willow were were who was the i forget chief product officer something like
that vice president of products i can't remember what his role was but he got me to interview i got
accepted i was actually gonna make the jump and i sat down with my boss and said hey i'm not gonna
work at netflix anymore and ultimately it was all because of those previous interactions and i
think there's a lot of things that i did that i failed there i really do wish i would have taken more
time and understood how i felt and kind of really das ist aber eine sache das habe ich auch schon bei
uns gemerkt also ich übertrag das übertragenden sinn das färbt auf die leute ab in welcher sprache
das netflix backend läuft keine ahnung es wird ja bestimmt nicht groovy sein was am anfang gesagt
hat also es färbt es färbt ab wenn du quasi vorgelebt bekommst also was du so vorgelebt
bekommst irgendwie das färbt mit der zeit ab und gerade wenn es eh nicht nicht gut läuft irgendwann
schaltest du in so einen modus wo du sagst eigentlich ist mir das alles wurscht ich mache
halt das was ich machen kann rest juckt mich nicht und ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
du dann zunehmend unfreundlich wirst auch zu den anderen leuten also ich bin ja mittlerweile schon
eine stufe weiter was das angeht mir ist es egal und ich bin also ich bin prinzipiell da auch zu
keinem unfreundlich es juckt mich einfach gar nicht mehr ja also wenn irgendein schwachsinn ist
denke ich mir ja mache schwachsinn ich bin um 15 30 weg es geht mir geht mir komplett am arsch
vorbei es wird so viel bullshit bei uns gemacht also sowohl auf technischer seite als auch auf
management entscheidung seite ich habe keine ahnung warum es diesen laden überhaupt noch gibt
teilweise ich kann es manchmal nicht nachvollziehen dass es dass es sich immer noch hält ich meine es
gibt so viele probleme und es sind so viele sachen mit ansage die gegen die wand fahren das verstehe
ich verstehe ich nicht das liegt aber auch großen teil daran wenn du auf entscheidungsebene sachen
schneller entscheidest als du sie am ende umsetzen kannst oder wenn oder wenn das führt einfach zu
fehlen ja am ende wird natürlich in der technik in der technik verkackt aber du musst halt auch
mal gucken die wie ist es dazu also wie kommt es denn dazu und das passiert eigentlich so gut wie
nie ja wahrscheinlich haben alle unternehmen wobei ich glaube ganz ehrlich ich habe ja auch
schon mit vielen externen bei uns gesprochen die vor allem die die auch noch nicht so lange da
sind das ist bei uns schon extrem der unterschied zwischen sagen und machen also es ist immer so
dass unternehmen sich geiler verkaufen als die sind und das ist auch immer so dass das alles in
superlativen dort erzählt wird und im endeffekt wird auch nur mit wasser gekocht aber bei uns ist
die diskrepanz zwischen der der selbst lobpreisung und dem dem dem selbstverständnis komplett
entkoppelt von der realität also wir finden uns um ein so vielfaches geiler als wir eigentlich
sind das hat mit der realität gar nichts mehr zu tun ja das ist bei allen so und das war als ich
beim provider davor gearbeitet auch so aber nicht so krass nicht so krass also bei uns erzählen die
sich regelmäßig dass sie die besten sind dass projekte prinzipiell gehen ja bei uns auch nie
schief projekte werden halt so lange um definiert bis dann am ende nicht mehr das eigentliche
gemacht werden soll nicht mehr gemacht werden muss was eigentlich gemacht werden sollte oder müsste
und was ist an so vielen stellen bei uns ist auch alles so super vage bei uns schreibt keiner deswegen
schreibe ich mir die ganzen sachen ja mittlerweile auf wenn irgendwo was entschieden wird ja bei uns
ist das alles immer so super vage so nach dem motto ja das musst du aber bei uns im change board
besprechen ja ok und wann weiß ich ab wann ein change relevant für das change board ist ja das
kann ich dir auch nicht so genau genau sagen dann gesunder menschenverstand auf der einen
seite wird immer erzählt man möchte dass alles mehr formalisieren mit prozessen auf der anderen
seite kommen sie immer an wenn sie dann wieder feststellen es funktioniert nicht ja gesunder
menschenverstand und ich habe mir schon ich habe mich glaube ich echt schon an einigen stellen
wirklich unbeliebt gemacht weil ich das halt wenn wieder mal was total entgegengesetztes war
angesprochen habe das stößt dann aber auch meistens für für unverständlich unverständnis
und eher den eher als dass die leute denken da max will nerven und also wisst ihr wisst ihr für
viele viele sagen immer gibt konstruktives feedback konstruktives feedback das stimmt
überhaupt nicht die leute sagen gibt konstruktives feedback was sie meinen ist sagt dass ich der
beste bin und wir der geilste laden auf der welt das meinen das eine sagen sie und das andere
meinen sie und konstruktives feedback wäre für mich auch zu sagen ja okay wir haben so was
ähnliches schon mal probiert das hat auch diese und diesen gründen nicht geklappt wir machen
gerade genau wieder das gleiche also ich sehe ich sehe die und die probleme genau wie das letzte
mal und das ist für mich schon konstruktives feedback aber das will man oftmals nicht hören
es besteht auch auf kaum einer ebene ich sage wille zur selbstkritik irgendwie es ist zum
beispiel ein ein beispiel ein beispiel dass ihr das ihr wisst was ich meine was was so
so gegensätzlich ist auf der einen seite möchte man das wartungsarbeiten möglichst klein gehalten
werden ja und möglichst fehlerfrei laufen was ja durchaus sinnvoll ist das würde ich das finde
ich das finde ich gut was man sagt okay wir machen lieber kleine wartungsarbeiten und haben
dann weniger ausweg und weniger fehler als dass wir eben ein paar große machen aber es spricht
keiner von vielen kleinen wartungsarbeiten weil wenn du was erledigen musst warst du in einer
riesen wartungsarbeit über mit nacht einsatz erledigen könntest dann kannst du es logischerweise
nicht in einer kurzen wartungsarbeit erledigen sondern vielleicht in fünf kurzen wartungsarbeiten
zu jeweils irgendwie in einer halben stunde verteilt ein bisschen okay meinetwegen aber das
musst du halt dann sagen du musst sagen ja wir machen dadurch mehr wartungsarbeiten das ist klar
wenn wir die wartungsarbeiten den umfang die komplexität und die fehlerquote aber reduzieren
dann werden es mehr wartung ist ja unter anderem eines der sachen wenn es um agilität und sonst
was geht so nach dem motto continuous was auch immer prozesse das macht man dann aber nicht
weil man auf der einen seite sagt wenn wir wollen lieber mehrere kleine möglichst ja
wartungsarbeit mit wenig auswirkung mit wenig impact wie man da im manager speak dazu sagt aber
auf der anderen seite macht man so viele change freezes und so viele dinge wo was nicht gemacht
werden darf und nach die hürden so groß das wiederum keiner kleine wartungsarbeiten planen
möchte das ist einfach eine diskrepanz zwischen dem dem dem sagen dass man das machen soll und
den anreizten dafür setzen dass man eigentlich dann in der praxis doch was anderes macht und
das andere ist eigentlich das was man nicht will wie gesagt es hat keinen sinn mehr ich
habe total oft zu solchen sachen schon was gesagt und wisst ihr was die beste aussage war das kein
witz die wurde wirklich getroffen zu solchen kritikpunkten von einem wirklich ziemlich hohen
management tut bei uns die antwort war ja wir wissen um unsere schwächen da ich auch ja ok
und jetzt und nun wir wissen unsere schwächen ist ja schön so nach dem motto einsicht ist der
erste weg zur besseren nur dass es bei uns besseren nie gibt also bei mir ist es mittlerweile so
ich sag euch ich sag euch ehrlich wie es ist ich fühle mich meinen arbeitskollegen mit denen ich
schon jahrelange zusammenarbeite in irgendeiner art und weisamer verbunden ich möchte die auch
nicht im stich lassen und ich will ich will jetzt auch nicht wegen denen irgendwie weg oder so ich
verstehe mich mit denen gut also ich fühle mich wirklich den leuten dort die schon jahre kenne
mit manchen würde ich sogar sagen würde ich bin ich sogar befreundet ja würde ich würde die
würde ich nicht sitzen lassen wollen ja und wenn mich jemand anruft am wochen da gehe ich auch
dran weil ich weiß da hockt jemand rum der jetzt gerade keine ahnung hat was er machen soll so das
ist das eine aus dem aus dem grund also das ist auch ein bisschen was was mich dann noch an der
arbeit motiviert ja ganz ehrlich ich habe das auch letztens ich habe das über letztens im
mitarbeitergespräch mit meinem chef noch reingeschrieben es gibt da so ein so ein
fragebogen dem am ende ausfüllen soll und da war eine frage was motiviert sie besonders auf
der arbeit wissen was ich reingeschrieben habe habe reingeschrieben mein team und mein gehalt
und das lasse ich auch so stehen weil wir was anderes behauptet ist komplett des illusioniert
so aber und jetzt und jetzt jetzt jetzt ernsthaft wie gesagt ich fühle mich den ich fühle mich
den leuten verbunden dort auf der arbeit mit denen ich jahre lang zusammenarbeitet die ich
auch gerne habe die ich auch mag mit denen ich auch gerne weiter zusammenarbeiten möchte aber
ich fühle mich halt gar nicht irgendwie den den wie soll ich sagen nicht den werten den
werten ist falsch die firma hat keine werte in dem sinn die sagen nur dass sie welche hätten ich
fühlt mich ich fühle mich in keinster weise irgendwie der firma verbunden sondern meinen
kollegen ja also die firma ist mir wirklich komplett egal ich würde auch einfach mit den
mit den vier fünf leuten mit denen ich mich gut verstehe mal genommen wir würden ein
angebot bekommen jungs kommt einfach mit den fünf leuten rüber zu uns und arbeitet dort
würde ich sofort machen dann mir geht es eher um die leute weniger um den weniger um den laden
an sich also mir ist die firma ziemlich egal aber die machen ja auch in den letzten paar
jahren alles dafür dass es einem immer weiter egal ist aber wie gesagt den den leuten fühle
ich mich verbunden und die würde ich auch nicht im stich lassen wollen ja so sieht es aus also
bei mir ist es eher persönliche sachen die mich da halten auf der anderen seite natürlich so
schlecht ist es dort jetzt auch nicht du weißt halt auf was du dich einlässt ich wie gesagt habe ich
auch gesagt werde ich am freitag noch mal sagen das ist das beste team seit seit seit ich bei
dieser firma bin was wir gerade haben und jetzt wollen sie reorganisieren er gibt überhaupt
keinen sinn aus meiner sicht ja zumindest hat ja bis jetzt auch keiner sinnvoll begründet warum
das so ist man hat bloß gesagt ja das machen wir weil weil ist so und warum wir wissen selber nicht
ja ich bin gespannt was da rauskommt aber es gibt halt so ein paar sachen wie gesagt ich will
nicht weg erstens wegen meinen kollegen und weil es dort auch an sich jetzt aber es ist jetzt
nicht irgendwie super schlecht oder so es hat den vorteil ich kenne den laden schon eine weile ich
weiß einfach auf was ich mich einlasse und ich weiß was ich von dem laden erwarten kann und was
nicht das ist ja auch schon mal was weil ansonsten wenn du wo neues hinkommst das gras sieht auf der
anderen seite immer grüner aus und dann bist du dann da oder denkst du dir näher gut die kochen
ja auch alle nur mit wasser ist ist halt so ja und da weiß ich wenigstens auf was ich mich einlasse
und als ich es komme ich da auch gut klar aber sollte da jetzt wirklich jemand auf die idee
kommen so nach dem otto es gibt kein home office mehr oder so also dann ist dann ist wirklich schicht
dem schacht spooky bowser castle music so wir gucken das video noch schnell fertig wo sind wir
stehen geblieben da warum hat er jetzt eigentlich gekündigt
habt ihr auch schon mal production down getakt also ich habe es bisher erst einmal geschafft
production down zu taken keckel also ich habe ich habe nur einmal production down getakt und das
war aber glücklicherweise sogar auf auftrag von jemand anderem ansonsten habe ich ein paar ruckler
und kleinere ausfälle verursacht so die letzten jahre über immer mal ab und zu relativ selten aber
production komplett dauernd habe ich nur einmal geschafft wisst ihr bei was das ist schon eine
ganze weile her als ich im rechenzentrum war und das war ein rechen moment rechenzentrum
netzwerkschrank das war ein netzwerkschrank aus der hölle ja so ungefähr nur schlimmer die
türken gar nicht mehr die du musstest du musstest damals hat immer ein gutes bild kabel kaos
kabel kaos du durftest die tür nicht aufmachen ja so ungefähr so sah der schrank aus damals ja
ungefähr so kommt ganz gut hin und also nicht so krass hier ja aber aber so so trifft es eigentlich
ganz gut und da gab es da gab es eine tür die konnte es schon nicht mehr zu machen weil wenn
du die tür geschlossen hast dann haben die kabel zu sehr in den netzwerkgeräte gedrückt so und ich
sollte damals also ihr hört es mich das ist schon ganz ganz schön eine ganze weile her ich sollte damals
sachen umpatschen und da war ein esx house dabei und naja es hat geruckelt beim umpatschen
wahrscheinlich weil die leute auch esx technisch das nicht richtig aus den configs irgendwie
rausgenommen haben oder sonst was warum heißt das eigentlich patschen ich habe keine ahnung
vielleicht weil es kabel sind so und das hat dann dazu geführt dass ich weiß bis heute nicht warum
dass die switch alle der meinungen waren sie müssen jetzt spedding tree neu aufbauen und dann
stand für fünf minuten das komplette netz weil spedding tree neu aufgebaut werden wurde und es
war damals ja alles layer 2 das komplette gebäude das komplette nachbargebäude und das komplette
rz das war alles ein layer 2 so also es war war schon ein bisschen ist schon jahre her ist schon
jahre her und da haben die dinge erstmal spedding tree neu aufgebaut und ist das netz stand halt
komplett für fünf minuten das war das einzige mal wo ich je production down getakt habe so
and it's because i didn't have communication and the talks that i should have had i wasn't
understanding myself as well as i should have and so if you find yourself in those situations
you got to speak up you got to approach your boss und if you're ich hab schon öfters bei uns auf
der arbeit was gesagt es juckt aber kein und your co-workers aren't good enough to listen like i
wasn't good enough to listen right you know i i failed my co-worker but ultimately my boss
should have also been there listening and making the situation which didn't happen dafür
ist er da led to a lot of probably a lot of heartache if you work at a company that doesn't support
you in that kind of sense that doesn't understand that things are kind of going wrong that it's
only causing more and more tension you probably need to start thinking about man merkt das man
merkt dass die leute gerade wenn die leute schon so im stress sind und dann noch irgendwelche
organisatorischen sachen dazu kommen die leute sind mega unfreundlich bei uns auf der arbeit
auch teilweise so manche hast du das gefühl wenn die in wenn die in tickets schreiben die sind die
sind die würden die am liebsten ins gesicht springen so dabei muss man sich doch einfach nur überlegen
wenn du selber so abgefuckt bist weil du laufend dich um tausend sachen kümmern musst du kannst
eigentlich davon ausgehen dass in der regel derjenige dem du sind ticket schreibst dass es
dem genauso geht und sich untereinander abfacken ist ehrlich gesagt das was nicht hilft also es
hilft jetzt auch demjenigen nicht der sauer ist oder der schlecht drauf ist weil das nächste mal
wird wird der andere den er wo er jetzt grad noch mal den den hammer ins ticket reingeschrieben hat
dann noch unfreundlicher sein zu ihm also dass das das gibt so eine spirale von alles fackt sich
gegenseitig ab habe ich bei uns zwischen manchen teams auch schon erlebt thommy danke für den
sub es gab bei uns leute die haben nur in beisein des chefs miteinander gesprochen es gab ganze
teams die haben quasi nur noch schriftlich kommuniziert und sowas wegen solchen dingern
und da muss ich halt ehrlich sagen dafür bin ich nicht in die it gegangen ich will was mit
technik machen und eigentlich ich habe keinen bock auf abfack social dinger die sollen einfach
sich mal alle am riemen reißen und fest und mal wieder auf den boden der tatsache zurückkommen
auch wenn ultra wichtig getan wird und immer so getan wird hier geht es um leben und tot es
geht bei einer bank in der regel nicht um leben und tot schon gar nicht wenn irgendwelche versicherungen
im außendienst verkauft werden oder so geht nicht es geht um geld es geht auch um viel
aber es geht nicht um leben und tot also das ist nix worüber man sich jetzt irgendwie da
halb umbringen müsste und die leute schlagen total über die strengen das ist mittlerweile ein so
aggressiver grundton mit manchen leuten ja glücklicherweise nicht mit allen dass ich
ja immer am liebsten gleich sagen würde jungs schlägerts auf ja
habe ich eigentlich erzählt dass ich mich das letzte mit einem
organisator im meeting gestritten habe weil der organisator nichts organisieren wollte
ne
im game adventure das ist sehr gut vielleicht wirklich zeit sich was anderes zu suchen habe
ich erzählt ja man sieht das bei uns du hast du hast komplett recht also manager je nachdem
ab welcher höhe die müssten nicht wirklich ahnung von technik haben aber man sieht es in den teams
wo die chefs ein bisschen ahnung von der technik haben dass es besser funktioniert
habe ich mich angeschaut erzähl ok die kurz die kurzvariante ich war auf unserem change daily
change meeting und dort gab es einen change den ich schon mal vor eins oder zwei wochen
vorgestellt habe cap nennt sich das ein change advisory board das ist so eitel shit das ist cool
wenn man so was hat da bespricht erwartungsarbeiten so und ich habe den gleichen change schon mal vor
eins zwei wochen vorgestellt auf dem cap und ich habe dann gesagt ok das ist der gleiche change wie
schon vor eins zwei wochen da hat sich nichts dran geändert es musste nur mal kurz verschoben werden
konnte nicht gemacht werden weil noch irgendwelche tests ausgestanden haben wir würden es dann
gerne diese woche machen aber es hat sich nichts geändert alle voraussetzungen genau gleich sagt
der change manager zu mir kein ding abgehakt genehmigt oder kommt dann so ein anderer typ der
der dafür bekannt ist immer rein zu grätschen warum weiß ich nicht kommt dann und meint so
das sind ja schon ganz schön ja weiß ich wie er es auch ausgedrückt hat ohne dass ich jetzt die
die begriffe dort sage ja das sind ja schon ganz schön kritische wartungsarbeiten und auch in
diesem und diesem bereich sollte da nicht noch einer der xy leute nachtschicht einsatz einsatz
haben und die wartungsarbeiten begleiten ist das der ls typ der ja der hatte auch was mit dem ls
zu tun ja das könnte der gleiche sein sollte das nicht noch die wartungsarbeiten begleiten
da habe ich dann habe ich gesagt ganz ehrlich finde ich nicht verkehrt wenn da jemand dabei ist
der das noch der die der die logs besser versteht von der anwendung warum nicht ja kann man kann
man doch machen ist doch ok und dann meint er ja dann dann dann soll der hat den name gesagt von
demjenigen der den change eingereicht hat man ja dann soll der mal dort sich drum kümmern habe
gesagt nein der soll sich da nicht drum kümmern das ist ein admin der den change durchführt das
ist einer von mindestens fünf leute die es in diesem change beteiligt sind es kann nicht sein
dass personenplanung und nacht einsätze planen und und anträge stellen dass leute nachts da sind
personalplanung von einem admin gemacht werden soll nur weil er zufälligerweise einen change
durchführt der damit was zu tun hat so und hat er gemeint nein nein das ist nicht das ist das
stimmt nicht das muss der admin planung sein es muss der admin nicht planen dann habe ich
halt zu ihm gemeint guck mal wir haben das wir haben unser change management und du bist
organisator dann organisiert das doch und dann hat uns der dann hat uns unser ober change manager
zurückgepfiffen hat gesagt jungs regt euch mal ab und ja zumindest zumindest danach haben wir
noch mal darüber gesprochen und sogar unser change management war der meinung selbstverständlich ist
das nicht die aufgabe des nachts durchführenden admins personalplanung zu machen und sie finden
es ein unding dass ein organisator nicht einfach das nimmt und dann organisiert er meint ja noch
zu mir so nach dem motto nee nee da müsst ihr dann zu mir kommen damit wtf also so ein scheiß regt
mich echt auf du kannst nicht alles immer abwälzen ich frage mich manchmal echt wenn
du dort wirklich der hat ein fucking job und den macht er nicht richtig und ich frage mich
manchmal wirklich wenn man so viele sachen auf techniker abwälzt wozu hat man denn die ganzen
leute dennoch manager haben ja durchaus eine sinnvolle position teamleiter auch organisatoren
change das sind alles sinnvolle position ich bin niemand der sagt alles was nicht technik ist
ist unsinnig gibt ja leute die sehen das so ich finde du kannst das gerade ab einer gewissen größe
ist das unrealistisch ja das hat alles seine daseinsberechtigung aber die leute müssen eben
das auch machen wofür sie da sind du kannst nicht sagen am endeffekt bleibt das an dem techniker
hängen der nachts schon der in den freiwillig nachts in einsatz macht deswegen mache ich ja
auch keine nacht einsätze mehr ewig keine nacht einsätze mehr gemacht habe ich auch nicht vor
sehe ich nicht ein mit apple und ei dass das auch so ein ding gewesen da hatte ich mich mit dem
richtig in den haren in der runde und das wenn es ein organisator ist dann muss es organisieren
ich verstehe es teilweise nicht leute ich verstehe ich verstehe es nicht und das ist das wo ich
letztes gemeint habe spooky das ist das wo ich letztes gemeint habe viele leute die in die it
gehen wollen die denken halt es geht zum größten teil um technik leute ich würde wie sagt man ich
würde drei kreuze machen ich fände es geil wenn es wirklich mal hauptsächlich um technik gehen
würde es ist immer irgendein organisatorischer bullshit drum herum es sind immer irgendwelche
stonks nicht stonks immer irgendwelche komischen bürokratischen hürden die man überwinden muss
und die sind teilweise so unglaublich nervig nicht die existenz dieser hürden sondern weil
dir nie einer sagen kann wie du es jetzt eigentlich richtig machst ja wir haben auch so viele meetings
ich habe teilweise tage da mache ich eine stunde am tag vielleicht was wenn überhaupt das ist
einfach nur gucken ist irgendwas passiert und der rest ist irgendwie gemiete eigentlich sollten
prozesse dafür da sein und das ist auch das was i tell sagt ist das wahrscheinlich was dir auch
jeder coach consulting firma oder sonst was sagt prozesse sind eigentlich dafür da um die abläufe
klarer zu machen damit jeder weiß was gemacht werden muss und eigentlich müssen sich die prozesse
an das jeweilige unternehmen anpassen und nicht nicht umgedreht also man macht nix aus dem man
macht kein muster beispiel aus dem buch und passt sich dann daran an sondern das unternehmen muss
sich in gewisser weise was überlegen und dann muss man die prozesse machen so dass die für das
unternehmen passen und dann eben so dass man sicherheit mehr sicherheit in der arbeit hat also
sprich wie ist es gedacht dass was gemacht wird da und da steht du befolgst das dann hast du schon
mal grob nichts vergessen dafür ist es eigentlich gedacht so problem ist nur bei uns wir tun immer
so als hätten wir da wahnsinnig viel am ende kann dir wirklich niemand sagen wie du was richtig
machst das fängt an mit wann musst du einen change denn überhaupt ab wann ist der change so
wichtig dass man ihn in der wartungsrunde vorstellen muss ja wie beantragst du neue systeme was machst
du wenn neue systeme abgebaut werden soll es ist alles so unglaublich vage und das regt mich bei
uns auf der einen seite tun wir immer so als hätten wir wahnsinnig viele prozesse machen aber es ist
alles unglaublich vage und undurchsichtig und es will einfach keiner einsehen es gibt auch nirgendwo
bereitschaft mal zur selbstkritik es gibt in der technik wenig bereitschaft zur selbstkritik ich
höre das natürlich auch nicht gerne wenn ich miss gebaut habe es gibt aber auch im ich sag mal
mittleren bis oberen management wenig einsicht und selbstkritik also ich habe beispielsweise noch
nie gehört dass man gesagt hätte das hat ja nicht so gut geklappt es ist alles immer ganz toll soll
ich euch mal was lustig erzählen wir haben mal eine umfrage gemacht auf der arbeit vom tüv war
die vom tüv mitarbeiter zufriedenheitsumfrage oder sowas vom tüv ja und da gab es dann so fragen wie
wie klar ist ihnen ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie es formuliert war aber sinngemäß war es war die
frage so wie klar sind die aufgaben formuliert also wissen sie was sie zu tun haben bei aufträgen
und sowas und da habe ich halt einfach gesagt 05 also konntest bewerten von 1 bis 6 5 ich weiß
bei den meisten aufträgen nicht was die leute von mir wollen und wenn einer sagt dass das muss die
das machst du jetzt mal ganz schnell dann weiß ich oftmals gar nicht was ich machen soll also ein
großteil der eigentlichen aufgabe geht überhaupt erst mal da rein überhaupt herauszufinden was
denn jetzt eigentlich gemacht werden muss geschweige denn überhaupt gut durchdacht ist und ob das
überhaupt gemacht werden sollte so und das habe ich angegriffen anscheinend war ich nicht der
einzige weil wir hatten in der tüv umfrage und die diese umfrage ging durch ging bei ging durch die
komplette firma werden umfrage 4,7 glaube ich war das ergebnis das ist nicht gut und das haben alle
das ist also kein it problem das ist ein kulturelles firmen kulturelles problem offensichtlich so
und wisst ihr was wir gemacht haben damit das nicht so schlecht aussieht das kein witz ist
echter wahnsinn wir waren in anderen bereichen ziemlich gut und in den meisten bereichen waren
wir eigentlich relativ mittelmäßig bis schlecht und wisst ihr was man dann gemacht hat als man
das ganze präsentiert hat hat man nicht nicht einfach vorgelesen wie die noten sind so für
sich und dann was zugesagt nein man hat das verglichen und wisst ihr mit was man das
verglichen hat mit einem vergleichsdatensatz und man hat sich natürlich jetzt ein vergleichsdatensatz
rausgesucht der noch schlechter war das heißt man hat uns immer auf der rechten seite gesehen
rechte seite ist gut linke seite ist schlecht man hat unsere ergebnisse immer auf der rechten
seite gesehen und den vergleichsdatensatz auf der linken seite ich meine im ernst ich weiß nicht
wie viele tausend dieser umfragen der tüft schon durchgeführt hat es gibt auf jeden fall ich bin
mir nicht mehr sicher ob die einzelnen punkte aus der immer der gleichen vergleichsdaten mänge
kam und da wirst du doch da wirst du doch was finden was schlechter ist und das ist halt einfach
so abfuckt daran sieht man dass solche sachen nicht gemacht werden aus wir wollen uns verbessern
sondern nur um sich zu bestätigen dass alles gut ist und wenn dann rauskommt das ist nicht alles
gut dann macht man nichts dran deswegen bin ich halt leider mittlerweile auf dem punkt dass ich
sag leute ich kümmere mich genau um meine sachen und die versuche ich allein schon aus eigenem
interesse möglichst fehlerfrei gut zu machen weil ich will mich nicht mehr als nötig damit
beschäftigen und ansonsten bin ich wenn ich weg bin bin ich weg also 15 30 ich schluss und wenn
mich nicht gerade noch kurz knapp danach eine anruft oder vielleicht ein kollege den ich gerne
habe am wochenende mache ich mir da keine gedanken drum und ich beteilige mich auch nachdem ich so
oft versucht habe mich dort einzubringen und ich habe bei so vielen leute ich habe bestimmt bei
fünf sechs verbesserungs workshops und und dinge ich habe sogar mal was vorgestellt und so mitgemacht
also mir kann keiner vorwerfen ich hätte da keinen einsatz gezeigt aber mittlerweile ist es
vorbei ich mache bei solchen dinge an in dieser firma nicht mehr mit weil ich weiß es kommt
eh nichts raus also es ist es ist sehr auf der anderen seite ist es für mich insofern befreiend
ich mache mir null gedanken sobald ich raus bin bin ich mit anderen sachen beschäftigt im
kopf und nicht mehr mit sachen in der firma passieren bin schon auf der suche nach einer
datacenter engineer stelle wenn du wenn ich weiß nicht was hat microsoft hat sie ist high
cluster infos high availability cluster infrastructure ich habe keine ahnung ich rate einfach nur wenn
du an hast kommst du aber bei den meisten sachen schnell rein weil man sagen muss von windows auf
linux ist schon ein hartes stück und von windows und von linux auf windows auch die sache ist
halt die die meisten windows admins möchten nicht linux administrieren und ich kenne keinen
linux admin der windows administrieren will kennt ihr jemand ernsthaft seid ihr linux admin und
sagt ihr ich würde gerne windows administrieren ich kenne keinen ich selbst mache ja relativ
wenig admin geschichten noch gerade im vergleich zu früher zu meiner provider turnschuh admin
zeit aber hat sich auch gelohnt hat man schon einiges gelernt aber ich rede öfters mit leuten die
im viel administratorische administrationstätigkeit waren und keiner von den linux leute können sich
ernsthaft vorstellen windows zu administrieren umgedreht ist es sagen umgedreht ist es von den
windows leuten habe ich durchaus schon gehört dass sie sich mit linux beschäftigen jetzt könnte
man sagen windows leute scheinen da toleranter zu sein aber linux leute wissen einfach den shit
will ich mir nicht geben und ich merke das manchmal ich muss jetzt einfach ein bisschen
mit bisschen mich drüber auslass ich gehe gleich pen ich merke einfach an manchen tagen wenn das
besonders nervig ist wenn der organisator mal wieder zugeschlagen hat oder irgendwelche anderen
wenn wenn viel heiße luft verzapft wurde da merke ich auch tage dass ich manchmal innerlich
so ein bisschen aggressiv werde und also ich würde lügen wenn ich sage ich habe es noch nie
ein bisschen ausgelassen sei es in irgendwelchen ticket antworten oder auch mal wenn ihm teams man
angerufen wurde oder so aber zum größten teil geht es mir mittlerweile so weit am hinteren vorbei
dass ich dann nicht versuche das irgendwie an den leuten auszulassen weil es macht es unterm
strich nicht besser weil wenn du abgefuckt bist kannst du von ausgehen die leute auf der anderen
seite auch gerade abgefuckt und wenn ihr euch dann gegenseitig noch abfuckt hat keiner was von
es ist sogar besser ich habe das mal ich habe das mal ich versuche ich versuche ich sage ich versuche das manchmal es
kostet es kostet mich überwindung aber was ich manchmal probieren ist wenn leute so richtig
eklig in tickets geantwortet haben dass ich dann entweder mega nett drauf antworte aber nicht so
aber nicht so nett so nach dem motto der max will mich verarschen sondern wirklich so als hätte ich
das jetzt überhaupt nicht gelesen was er geschrieben hat dass es negativ war oder manchmal habe ich auch
schon mit den leuten dann telefoniert im teams und was witzig ist wenn wenn du nach den ersten zwei
setzen wenn du nicht gleich anruft und sagt alter was das für eine bescheuerte antwort sondern wenn
du einfach sagst ok ich sehe anscheinend ist das aus eurer sicht nicht hoch genug priorisiert kannst
mir jetzt noch mal langsam erklären was jetzt eigentlich das ist was wir machen sollen und wie
habt ihr euch das vorgestellt die leute sind instant normal wieder bis bis auf ein paar
oberspassen gibt es natürlich auch ja wir haben auch leute die sind immer kurz vorm kurz vorm
schreianfall aber ich habe auch schon einmal bisher nur aber gerade mit solchen leute ich habe auch
schon gesagt soll ich mache jetzt ich ich mache jetzt das sprich aus das gebe ich mir jetzt nicht
länger tschüss zu ja aber das ist also das muss ich mir nicht anrufen also wenn da einer
ist am ausflippen ist ja gut ja das frage ich das frage ich mich auch manchmal
ach nee du hast zu wenig mütigst ja das ist auch gut dass das ist wahrscheinlich der grund das
wahrscheinlich der grund warum der laden läuft weil ihr was macht das ist wahrscheinlich weil
ihr was macht läuft der laden wird bestimmt beides gesucht
letztes als ich wandern war habe ich auch habe ich auch ein ein traktor eine traktorfahrerin sogar
gesehen da dachte ich mir man merkt doch dass wir im jahr 2022 sind hat man wie habe ich habe ich
mich am anfang des teams ein bisschen drüber ausgelassen wir leben schon tatsächlich in
zeiten die besser sind in dieser hinsicht als jemals gegeben hat heute macht noch nicht mal
mehr einer blöde sprüche über sowas oder hätte die sich wahrscheinlich sonst was anhören müssen
denn es war wirklich eine traktorfahrerin nicht nicht gegendert geschrieben es war wirklich
eine traktorfahrerin das finde ich gut die muss ich weder blöde denke ich mal zum gründen muss
ich wahrscheinlich weder blöde blöde sprüche anhören noch sonst was das wäre von paar keine
warnung wäre wahrscheinlich vor vor 30 jahren anders gewesen ich mache auch viele emojis in
ticket ich habe sogar ab und zu schon mal null reingeschrieben bisher hat aber noch keiner
darauf geantwortet mit twitch emotes ja ich würde es auch hassen also ein wenig ja das
ist übrigens das zweite bei der way ich habe ich habe ja vorhin gesagt also ich will eigentlich
dort bleiben wo ich jetzt gerade bin es sei denn sie sagen wirklich homeoffice wird abgeschafft
dann würde ich es mir ganz stark überlegen da wäre ich wahrscheinlich ins den weg oder wenn
sie sagen ich soll jetzt noch zusätzlich windows administrieren obwohl ich schon wenig
administration mehr mache ich soll jetzt auch noch windows zusätzlich machen das würde ich
auch nicht machen also windows es gibt zwei sachen homeoffice streichen oder windows das
sind beides dinger die würde ich nicht machen also windows können sie mir komplett damit gestohlen
bleiben und ohne homeoffice auch nicht weil ich sehe es nicht ein ich mache im homeoffice mehr
als vorher und mir geht es besser also ist für mich gut und es ist für die firma gut
wenn man das dann nicht möchte dann ist unverständnis was nutzt ihr denn als ticket system
wie die coolen leute das aussprechen tips für das vorstellungsgespräch für was ausbildungsstelle
praktikum job wie sie ausbildung schwer zu sagen wenn man wenn man wenn man die firma nicht kennt
also ich kann dir sagen ich kann dir sagen wie das bei mir gelaufen ist ich weiß es ist
wahrscheinlich recycle story das habe ich wahrscheinlich schon hier haben die paar leute
schon gehört was nach dem letzten stream am morgen danach zusage stream verstehe ich nicht
zumindest also ich kann dir sagen wie es bei mir gelaufen ist hast du jeden tag homeoffice ja außer
dienstag da fahre ich nach frankfurt und ich arbeite auch nur vier tage in die woche also
bei mir für die für die ausbildungsstelle damals war das so wir sind wir sind angekommen
und mussten erst mal so einen komischen test machen dieser test war ein test den sie eigentlich
ihren fertig gelernten admins geben und da waren fragen drinne sowie wie editieren sie
im wim das und das welche iptables tabellen kennen sie das war so richtig hardcore admin
shit es ist gucci und sonst was sie wollten wirklich ordentlich was wissen und ein paar
sachen wusste ich halt ja ich habe ein bisschen wimm gemacht schon und ich hatte ein bisschen
ahnung von was programmieren angeht damals schon und ich hatte auch ich konnte ich konnte
minimal ich wusste dass man ein n machen muss enable machen muss aufs diskus sie allein sowas
so dann sagt muss man doch irgendwelche komische tests zumindest nach dem test ging es dann
darum der der damalige chef ist dann in den warteraum gekommen und hat gesagt soll jungs
jungs und medels ich weiß nicht was er gesagt hat so leute oder irgendwas so wer möchte
den anfangen wir machen wir fangen jetzt mit dem forst mit dem vorstellungsgespräch
wer möchte anfangen und da haben die sich alle so angeguckt wir hatten einen dabei der ist da
so richtig super krass gestyled im anzug gekommen aber der hat den kompletten anzug fast durch
geschwitzt also der war so krass nervös das habe ich noch nie gesehen der hat gezittert
und geschwitzt und war rot im gesicht er war fertig mit den nerven also der war so und der
wollte nicht und und die anderen wollten auch nicht und da habe ich halt okay gehe ich halt
ja also oft gehts bin ich rein und ich habe damals glaube ich was relativ unwissend unwissend
ja was relativ cleveres gemacht und zwar also wie gesagt keine taktik war einfach eher was
spontanes wir haben uns hingesetzt und ich habe gemerkt dass die zwei auf der anderen
seite auch kurz nichts gesagt haben und ich wollte so sie so so so akward silence vermeiden
so dieses man guckt sich an wie gehts jetzt los und dann habe ich halt einfach gesagt
so also der ansteht der test war schon ganz schön gemein an manchen stellen und darauf
hin haben wir gefragt warum ja warum habe ich dann gesagt ja aber ip tables es war es
ist mir eingefallen das andere muss ich in sysco cli war ich auch schon mal eigentlich
bin ich mal eingefallen ich hätte da glaube ich viel mehr beantworten können für wenn
es jetzt zu anderen zeitpunkt gewesen wäre jetzt hatte ich das kann alles nicht mehr
im kopf und ja von da an ging es eigentlich weiter ja oder oder wie mckay sagen würde
ich bin als auf dem mont everest gestiegen von da an ging es nur noch bergab also von
da ging es eigentlich von da ging es dann haben sie mich gefragt wie es mit meinem dsl
anschluss aussieht daheim und was ich da machen würde und eigentlich alles in ordnung und
ein tag später morgens um acht das war die leute morgens um acht stell euch das mal vor
das war noch zeiten da das war nach dem zivildienst und so da habe ich gewöhnt da habe ich gepennt
bis sonst wann habe ich morgens um acht angerufen und zwar an die personalabteilung vom provider
und haben gesagt ja herr max wir würden sie gerne einstellen aber das ist ja cool tach
später ansonsten ganz ehrlich ich glaube nicht dass man das nach so so einem wirklichen
muster leitfaden irgendwie machen kann mit dem vorstellungsgespräch man kann es aber
üben denke ich also ich denke es ist was und also was also was ich sagen will es ist
ein unterschied ob man sich einfach nur eine leitfaden durchliest und dann hofft dass alles
wenn man live dort ist dort dort sitzt irgendwie abrufen zu können das klappt nicht ihr habt
keine übung und ihr könnt wenn ihr nervös seid auch nicht gut nachdenken das ist so
deswegen macht man ja kreative sachen oder feinden motorische sachen oder soll ich sagen
nicht wirklich unter belastung und stress ja und ich kann ich kann das nicht abrufen
also stellt euch mal vor ihr habt jetzt in fünf seiten guide gelesen mit den besten
tips der welt und ihr habt es noch nie geübt ihr könnt doch ihr könnt doch das gar nicht
im kopf dann wenn ihr nervös seid alles abrufen wichtig ist dass man es entweder so
blauäugig macht wie ich und glück hat oder dass man das vorher mal ein bisschen geübt
hat ich habe einfach irgendwas gesagt das hat funktioniert vielleicht haben wir erkannt
der max wird mal mit prime subs richtig big brain weiß ich nicht aber ich habe glück
gehabt ja ich war nicht wirklich gut auf vorstellungsgespräche vorbereitet aber nach irgendeinem fahrplan
so nach dem motto ja ich muss jetzt hier sagen und auf diese antwort sage ich das
ich denke also ich kann auch mal eine sache sagen wisst ihr was mir unglaublich geholfen
hat und warum ich mittlerweile gerne präsentationen halte also okay da muss da muss ich da muss
ich gerade mal ganz kurz ganz ein bisschen ein bisschen auswählen also ich habe es
früher in der schule und sonst wo gehasst präsentation zu machen ich mochte ich mochte
ich weiß bettgetheim eigentlich ich mochte das überhaupt nicht so und ein nachteil dabei
war also ein grund warum ich das nicht gerne gemacht habe war okay ne sorry vergesst aber
ich muss das anders sagen ich habe das nicht gerne gemacht so und eine sache die es nicht
besser gemacht hat ist dass ich dadurch dass ich es nicht gerne gemacht habe mich auch
nie drum gekümmert habe das heißt ich habe das ignoriert bis ein tag vorher hat mir
irgendwas notgetrunken zusammengereimt habe mir dann fast in die hose gemacht davor habe
die präsentation gehalten die war natürlich mega scheiße weil ich nicht richtig darauf
vorbereitet war und danach habe ich das direkt wieder verdrängt so so habe ich präsentation
in der schule gehalten und das war natürlich vom ansatz her doof ich weiß es geht es geht
vielen leuten so zumindest was mir dann wirklich geholfen hat ist erstens das zu realisieren
dass wenn man sich mit dem thema beschäftigt man deutlich bessere präsentationen hält
als wenn man einen tag vorher zwei stunden sich irgendwas hinkriegselt wenn man sich
mit dem thema beschäftigt und es heißt noch nicht mal dass man irgendwie der super master
profi werden muss in dem thema aber man sollte zumindest eine gewisse ahnung haben von was
man da spricht so das ist das ist wichtig also man sollte ein bisschen ahnung haben
von dem was man da präsentiert also man muss sich tatsächlich mit dem thema beschäftigen
und wir reden hier gar nicht von einem riesen zeitaufwand also vorher habe ich einen tag
vorher 20 minuten irgendwas hingeklatscht und habe das dann vorgelesen am anderen tag
und dementsprechend war meine präsentation auch richtig beschissen und jetzt mache ich
auch nicht so viel mehr zeit einsatz ich versuche aber die präsentation über über sagen wir
mal eine woche oder zumindest zwei drei tage über zusammen zu klicken immer mal wieder
mit pausen weil wenn man was macht und pausen das hat man immer wieder mal gute ideen zwischendurch
und von 20 minuten zeit einsatz bin ich vielleicht jetzt bei vier fünf stunden zeit einsatz
für eine präsentation ja es ist nicht so dass es jetzt ultra ausufert oder so ich
brauche weniger als einen arbeitstag insgesamt über halt mehrere tage verteilt um mich da
auf sowas vorzubereiten und was mir zusätzlich auch noch geholfen natürlich motivation wenn
man da mal was gutes gehalten hat und es kommt gut an ist natürlich auch wahnsinn aber was
mir auch tatsächlich geholfen hat ist zusätzlich noch so blöd es klingt dass ich angefangen
youtube videos zu machen und eigentlich davon nur eine sache und zwar so standard rede wendung
vielleicht ist es euch schon aufgefallen aber eine sache die ich immer sage wenn mir wenn
ich nicht weiter weiß wo ich versuche das mittlerweile bisschen zurückzufahren ist was
ich gerne sage ist also ich sag was dann fällt mir was fällt mir nicht ein wie ich weiter
machen soll und dann sage ich dann sowas wie ja und was was auch noch wichtig ist also
was man auch noch zusätzlich erwähnen muss ist das ist so eines meiner fülldinger schlechthin
weiß ich aber ich habe aufgefallen das sage ich total oft und ich habe so 5 6 rede wendung
fülldinger mir angewöhnt durch die youtube videos und ich sobald ich die sage komme ich
irgendwie automatisch in den nachdenken modus und das funktioniert wenn du im nachdenken
modus bist du brauchst eine sekunde da fällt dir wieder ein du brauchst eine fokussierte
sekunde das reicht da fällt dir sofort wieder ein was du jetzt eigentlich sagen wolltest
wenn du da vorne stehst vor allem wenn du es relativ frei machst und dann gehts weiter
also wirklich so 5 4 5 gute überleitungs füllsätze zu haben ist wirklich gold wert
bei präsentation einfach nur eine pause machen kommt auch an wie lange du nachdenken
musst kannst du kannst du auch machen du kannst dich auch kurz verklicken auf der presi aber
dann musst du mit dem kopf beschäftigt also ich ich mache meistens in langsam eingeschobenen
füllsatz und das funktioniert bei mir am besten in der zeit kann ich dann auch gut
nachdenken und am besten ist ohne mist einfach übung wenn man das ein paar mal gemacht hat
und den man vor allem gutes feedback motiviert natürlich auch wenn die leute sagen das war
wirklich interessant und wenn du merkst auch die hören dir alle zu und wenn man ein bisschen
übung hat dann hilft das und das hilft bei vorstellungsgesprächen sicherlich auch
ja aber mittlerweile mache ich das wirklich gerne sachen präsentieren es es müssen
aber sachen sein auf die ich irgendwie bock habe also wenn jetzt einer sagt präsentieren
mal die neuesten bvl fakten da würde ich auch nur machen
ne mache ich nicht kein bock drauf also es muss schon irgendwas sein wo mich das thema
zumindest ein bisschen interessiert
ach du hast die zusage bekommen für das vorstellungsgespräch oder so stimmt stimmt ich erinnere mich
mal ich wollte kurz dein profilbild gucken dann weiß ich nicht ob du das bist keine
ahnung aber ich erinnere mich ich erinnere mich
dran da war hat letztens jemand was gefragt ja da wir haben auch über über zusagen
und und bewerbung sach geredet aber das kommt öfters vor ich weiß nicht ob du das warst
aber wird ja wird ja passen taimo danke für den sub war vor ein paar tagen ja ich leider
warst du das ich hatte auch kein anzug an
das ist das ist tatsächlich nicht nicht nicht nicht gut
das ist gut ja aber ganz ehrlich ich war auch nicht im anzug da ich werde auch zu keinem
vorstellungsgespräch im anzug gehen sobald wobei ich meine mittlerweile könnte ich fast
wieder ich müsste wieder in den anzug reinpassen fast
er ist halt schon 20 jahre alt oder so
nein da passe ich noch nicht rein das dauert noch ein bisschen 96 reicht da noch nicht
ich mag das nicht endpunkt mochte das richtig mein extra zubi mit dem ich ein video aufgenommen
hab der stand richtig auf anzüge
es ist tatsächlich viel übungssache ja das problem ist wenn du dich nicht darauf vorbereitest
also wenn du das klein wenn du den gleichen fehler machst wie ich du hast kein bock drauf
du weißt dass du dir fast schon in die hose macht dementsprechend versuchst du das so
lange wie möglich zu ignorieren und du bereitest dich nicht darauf vor und dadurch dass du
dich nicht darauf vorbereitest wird es dann genau wie du es erwartet hast also du erwartest
es wird beschissen du bereitest dich nicht darauf vor und dadurch wird es beschissen
weißt du was ich meine also das erfüllt sich dann selbst
natürlich wirst du nicht von jetzt auf gleich nicht mehr nervös sein wenn du irgendwas
präsentieren muss und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich glaube jeder der behauptet er ist
gar nicht nervös wenn er sich da auf irgendwie es muss ja nicht immer eine bühne sein wenn
er sich da irgendwie vorne an alles an den präsentations geht an den fernsehstellen
oder so und es sitzen dann irgendwie 20 leute im raum dass der gar nicht nervös ist selbst
ganz ehrlich selbst irgendwelche leute die schulungen machen und sowas die werden nicht
nervös sein aber die werden auch eine gewisse anspannung haben wenn sie da sitzen im raum
und es kommen dann 30 leute rein die sie das erste mal sehen und so ich glaube da kannst
du gar nichts dagegen machen ich meine selbst weltstar sagen ja wenn sie live auf eine bühne
gehen gewisse nervosität ist immer da aber was halt hilft ist wenn du es in der vergangenheit
schon ein paar mal nicht verkackt hast dann hast du eine gewisse gewisse sicherheit da
drin und du weißt dass du es trotz dieser anspannung hinkriegst und man darf nicht vergessen
ein bisschen anspannung ist gar nicht schlecht weil ein bisschen anspannung führt dazu dass
du fokussierter bist und besser nachdenken kannst also schneller bist sobald es aber zu
zu stress wird ist vorbei also wie gesagt am besten das beste was du wirklich machen
kannst ist auch wenn du gar keinen bock auf diesen scheiß hast weil du weißt du hast
es und du weißt es lief nie gut versuch dich zumindest mal ein bisschen darauf vorzubereiten
und nicht erst wie ich das früher gemacht habe 20 20 minuten einen tag vorher irgendwas
hinzukriegseln du musst gar nicht viel zeit reinstecken aber versuchst halt einfach dass
du mal zwei drei tage vor und das ist manche leute sagen sie planen ihre präsentation
monate in advance so nach dem motto einfach zwei drei tage vorher 20 minuten mal die
überlegen ausarbeiten ok was kann ich denn präsentieren vielleicht schon ein paar slides
machen überlegen dass es mal ein tag setzen dann machst du du brauchst du machst einfach
aus 20 minuten eine stunde verteilt über drei tage und du wirst sehen du hast gleich
mehr ahnung wovon du sprichst und dementsprechend wird automatisch deine präsentation und
deine gespräche was auch immer besser und wenn du es ein paar mal gemacht hast du musst
nie der große präsentator werden wenn du da keinen bock drauf hast wirst du feststellen
es ist gar nicht mehr so beschissen wie am anfang aber ich weiß dass ist schwierig zu
sagen weil das ist ähnlich wie leute die sagen sie haben angst vor spinnen oder so
ich bin auch kein großer spinnen fan muss ich sagen das ist halt auch nicht wirklich
rational irgendwo also ich weiß dass mir gerade spiel sind ja nicht in australien dass
mir spinnen die hier leben in der regel nichts tun können trotzdem mag ich spinnen nicht
das ist nicht wirklich begründbar spoderman ja ja und vorbereitung wie gesagt weil ich
sage vorbereitung ist alles wenn du die möglichkeit hast das 1 2 3 mal vorher zu halten das bringt
wirklich was die suchen so viele leute die gibt sich ja da gibt sich sicherlich noch
neue chancen es mag vielleicht für dieses jahr sein aber es gibt leute den azubis abspringen
und die suchen alle hände ringen fachpersonal also du hast auf jeden fall noch chancen und
leute ich habe auch vorher eine bescheuerte bvl ausbildung gemacht und habe dann als
ich älter war noch mal die fachinformatik ausbildung gestartet du darfst das nie abschreiben
komplett wenn du das machen willst wenn es was ist was dich interessiert das ist ja das
wichtigste was du persönliches interesse dran hast vor allem in einer branche die so hände
ringen leute sucht da hast du auf jeden fall noch chancen ja aber wie gesagt präsentation
ein paar mal halten ist nicht verkehrt dass das hilft das hilft wenn nach möglichkeiten
probiere ich das auch und ich ich habe festgestellt die präsentationen sind immer besser nachdem
man sie ein zweimal gehalten hat einfach dadurch ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß nicht wie man
das wie man dieses phänomen nennt aber es gibt es gibt so ein es gibt so ein phänomen
ich weiß nicht wie man es nennt also wenn ihr wenn ihr die sache wenn ihr eine sache
zwei drei mal macht und ihr macht die dann ein viertes mal dann erinnert ihr euch wenn
ihr das gleiche ein viertes mal macht erinnert ihr euch spontan an die sachen die die zwei
drei mal vorher waren und dementsprechend wisst ihr viel besser den text ohne abzugucken
und ihr könnt auch viel besser überleitung und sowas machen also mir ist es schon oft
so gegangen ich habe ich habe das ganze zwei drei mal geübt und wenn ich dann die eigentliche
präsentation machen musste dann habe ich angefangen und quasi ab dem dritten satz
habe ich mich quasi im kopf hatte ich den ablauf von der letzten von der letzten probe
quasi und ich konnte das insofern dann noch besser machen weil ich wusste jetzt nach
dem motto okay nach dieser folie kommt die und da ist das blöde bild unten links und
da konnte ich dann auch so vom um dann konnte ich dann quasi sogar sagen vom umschalten
so nach dem motto jetzt ganz kurz bevor ich die nächste folie hin umschalte ja nicht
lachen das thema ist ernst dann umschalten und dann sieht man halt ein blödes bild auf
der folie sag ich ja aber das hat schon seinen sinn und das sind halt so sachen die du einbauen
kannst wenn du gewissen so gewissen guide im kopf hast ja und das funktioniert das
ist übungssache das nennt man autismus sagt der chat ne glaube ich nicht das hat damit
nichts zu tun und selbst wenn wenn ich mir so recht überlege ist eigentlich ziemlich
blödes kommend twitter kommt gleich ja twitter ist immer gleich am start pass auf pass auf
notorious twitter schätzt ordentlich gleich dann ist vorbei bei twitter weiß man ja nie
was das ist irgendwo im nirgendwo donau wird zum teufel ist donau wird ich habe keine ahnung
ist da leute so jetzt muss ja wirklich ins bett any percent zu any any any percent speedrun
stream verabschiedung also leute wir sehen uns im nächsten stream machts gut bis denn
tschüss